we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors if you're trying to quit
smoking or vaping check out lucy which
is a nicotine gum developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save 20
when you go to lucy.co and use coupon
code pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started you really have to
see to believe the things that
are happening on fox news from all sorts
of people
who just cannot cope with the reality
that donald trump has lost and it's
actually
starting to get hilarious because of how
stupid and cultish
it is let's go through a few clips it'll
be a whirlwind tour of the last day or
two on fox news
uh this is really great here is fox news
anchor ainsley earhardt on
yesterday morning's fox and friends
episode
she's sort of begrudgingly saying i
guess that guy they're sort of calling
the president-elect
joe biden the petulance the
stubbornness it's just palpable here
listen to this and uh steve ducey's son
peter
who has been on the campaign trail and
now he's with uh
with what they're calling the
president-elect biden what they are
calling president-elect biden isn't that
just a delight they
they can't they can't cope they just
can't
it's it's stunning the inability to just
accept that they've lost
and then after of course uh earlier this
week
the electors in all 50 states voting
officially giving joe biden the status
of president-elect
not media designated anymore but elector
designated president-elect on wednesday
night
trump uh white house press secretary
and senior adviser to the trump campaign
kaylee mcinanny
appeared on fox news and just wildly
accused the courts of
gimmickry tricks i don't know if she met
gimmicky tricks gimmickry is a word it's
unclear if she's actually
using it the right way anyway kaylee
just can't take
anything including the fact that courts
recognize
that every single one of the 50 claims
that the trump campaign has made or
without merit take
a look here's what they did sean here
was the clever little trick and it
happened in nevada
when the claims were brought beforehand
when we warned and said
hey mass mail in voting is a problem we
brought these courts
we brought these claims to a court of
law they said hey your claim's not right
come back after the election we bring it
after the election to the same court and
they say
latches which is a legal doctrine saying
your claim is too late
it can't not be ripe and then be too
late those are the kind of gimmickery
tricks that happened
and we've got to try to fix this because
2022 is on the line 2024.
she just can't handle it and she will
never stop
she some have jumped ship some of the
rats have abandoned the ship
kaylee is committed to going down
with the ship and by gimmickry i guess
she means civil procedure
due process constitutional elections
democracy the will of the people that's
now called gimmickry
to kaylee mcinanni then we move on to a
sitting
senator republican senator rand paul
yesterday morning also on fox and
friends
saying without a shred of irony
whatsoever
that the election was absolutely
stolen from by joe biden from donald
trump
do you think the election was stolen you
tweeted out absolutely i think there's a
great deal of fraud
50 court decisions won't convince him
statistical analyses won't convince him
he will insist no matter what that it
was stolen
and of course he golfs with trump and i
i don't think that the personal
relationship with trump should be
ignored here
at at least at least as part of the
reason part of the reason why
rand paul is saying this stuff here's
another
insane one this is a different fox news
show
and it's republican congressman ken buck
ken buck
is so unable to cope with what's going
on
that he is calling for an investigation
into hunter biden
possibly even criminal charges against
not only hunter by
but even joe biden as well american
people are fed up with corruption in
washington dc
i think they're fed up with people
selling their office
for personal gain and that's exactly
what it appears
president-elect biden did and if he
didn't do it
we need to have a special counsel to
clear the air it's the special counsel
that should be answering the questions
just like special counsel mueller
investigated president trump and cleared
him if
president-elect biden is cleared so be
it if he's not cleared
we need to make sure that we proceed
with criminal charges against hunter
biden
and if necessary against joe biden when
he leaves office
buck can't even get his facts straight
or maybe more likely he doesn't care
about the facts
robert mueller did not clear donald
trump robert mueller actually says
in plain language he cannot clear trump
on obstruction
and if he could clear trump on
obstruction he would have said i can
clear trump on obstruction
and ken buck going off into uh
fantasyland
now here's my question for you is this
more sad or infuriating
or is it is it both and
i i'm leaning towards it's both like it
it is infuriating that these people are
in positions of power
it's infuriating that these people hold
the bully pulpit and and set the agenda
on media and and all of that and maybe
i'm too
you know one of the things that we know
about the right is they are completely
unempathetic
uh until something affects them directly
maybe i'm too empathetic but i i find it
sad
to see adults behaving in this way just
completely unable to cope
uh with with what is a political loss
here um and i think over the next
listen there's kind of three uh time
frames that i'm looking at it's the next
few weeks until
january 20. what do we see on right-wing
media and from republicans during that
period of time
then what do we see during the first few
months of the joe biden presidency
and then what will right-wing media sort
of settle into
for the duration of biden's term and my
expectation is
again it depends on what trump will do
and how visible trump will be in
continuing to foment this insanity
but i think republicans in right-wing
media will get back to all the normal
playbook
um thinly veiled anti-semitic tropes as
we saw from tucker carlson yesterday
pretending to care about the debt and
deficit all of the normal stuff that
we've come to see from them
curious to hear from you i am really
glad
to see that national security experts
are increasingly using a term
that i've been talking about on the
program for years and that you may now
be familiar with in that term
is stochastic terrorism to describe
what donald trump is doing we have now
heard
from such national security experts as
juliette cayem
and others who are saying that when
donald trump
goes out there and insists that it's
been stolen
and says we they must resist then that
they must
fight and that it's uh an attack on
his voters and democracy and all of
these things when he
makes these claims about electoral fraud
that are both completely unequivocal
from trump
but completely baseless in fact
donald trump is making it more likely
that some of his followers are going to
go out and take to the streets and do
real world violence and the people
that sometimes speak on trump's behalf
will often hide behind these are
sometimes
jokes that are being told or things are
being taken too literally or whatever
the case may be
but as juliet kyam points out and this
is written about in a very good
mother jones article um we've also heard
from others like
corey shaikh and and other people
um this can really encourage people to
go completely crazy with real world
violence and the term stochastic
terrorism refers to the idea
that uh stochastic terror terrorism
refers to
random but predictable violence okay
if my audience is big enough and i every
day
say somebody should really do something
about
joe joe schmoe something somebody really
needs to
deal with the problem of joe schmo joe
schmoe is attacking our way of life
joe schmo if he's allowed to continue
doing what he's doing is going to be the
end of america as we know it
if my audience is big enough it becomes
predictable
that someone in my audience is going to
take that to heart and commit an act of
real world world violence now
it will be random in terms of who does
it where and when that's
that's where the term stochastic
terrorism comes from
we're talking about a confidence
interval we're talking about uh you know
it it refers to
terms often used in finance and science
and relating to distributions
but if the if you're speaking to enough
people
it becomes predictable that somebody is
going to take action and that is exactly
what a lot of national security experts
are are now saying
and uh senior federal law enforcement
officials
uh have been saying that the level of
concern is extremely
high that they are seeing threatening
rhetoric
and and levels of anger as a result of
the things that donald trump and his
defenders who continue to claim he
actually won
joe biden didn't really win it was
stolen there was fraud it's all part of
the conspiracy
uh this is something that is very
dangerous and i'm glad to see national
security experts speaking in no
uncertain terms and the term stochastic
terrorism
is exactly the right one my hope is
that uh this will not turn to real world
violence
beyond what we have already seen and we
already saw some of it at the so-called
million mega march which fell just a
little short of a million people over
the weekend
um i hope that it doesn't come to that
let me know
what you're thinking about this i'm on
twitter at deepakman
we will take a break and have a
fantastic program for you today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the show remember the
number one way to support the david
pakman show
very easy grab yourselves a membership
at joinpacman.com
i cannot speak to what types of
discounts will be legal when joe biden
is president
so a great time to take advantage of the
coupon code
fresh start which will save you
70 percent an unconscionable amount of
money
let's hear from some folks in the
audience via discord
davidpakman.com slash discord
starting with david from st louis david
from st
louis you're on the air what's going on
hi well you can hear me
yes i can you're coming in beautifully
all right great uh thanks for taking my
call pleasure um
yeah so i had a couple questions for you
um so first i understand that you
generally support uh the national
popular vote and the interstate compact
yes now before we go any further make
sure to turn on
uh do not disturb on discord because
we're starting to get the discord
coming in over your voice and that's
that's a pain i am definitely new to
this so
oh boy can you hear me i i can
yes yeah i'm not trying to do that so
i'm just going gonna mute
my um odd my sound while i'm talking is
that okay
okay beautiful all right so uh my
question is about the national popular
vote interstate compact
basically i understand that you support
that um so my question is
um in terms of ranked choice voting
which i'm i've become more interested in
lately
um what what are your thoughts on like
the valid criticisms of that
and also just kind of like personally
who would you have ranked in terms of
like your
top three let's say for the latest
presidential election
um my top of people who actually of the
people who ran
i would have ranked joe biden first
so i i you know if you're asking about
theoretically people who didn't who
didn't run
but from who was on the ballot in
november third i would have ranked biden
one
but maybe i'm misunderstanding that
piece we've got a bunch of segments
about
ranked choice voting and different
versions of it there are versions of
ranked choice voting in which
theoretically the person who wins is one
that did not actually have a plurality
of
first choice votes and that's something
that i think we should seek to avoid
but there are some other methods and i
don't remember now because the the
expert we interviewed about it was about
a year ago
it may be single transferable vote that
resolves that problem
but i think that a national popular vote
with
some version of single transferable vote
uh
would be very interesting i think it's
extraordinarily unlikely that all of
these
things get changed at once and so um
i think that the the lowest hanging
fruit
is individual states like for example
maine
changing away from a first past the
voting system
while at the same time we pushed the
national popular vote interstate compact
but
these things would work nicely together
but they are two different things and
they're
likely to be if if successes are going
to be achieved they likely will not be
at the same time
yeah so so that was the the one you just
described before about the um
the the one that i heard of was from
andrew yang because i was following him
uh during the election and he was
describing it the way like you could you
know put your number your top
person let's say based on policy that
you were most you know that you
believed you like most supported and
then maybe put second or third the
person that you thought was mostly gonna
win so let's say
for me it would have been like andrew
yang maybe elizabeth warren and then joe
biden or not necessarily that order but
the idea that you could put your top
person first and then
um if they don't get the enough um the
requisite amount of votes to
you know move forward with like
plurality let's say then you know joe
biden gets all those votes
that's exactly the idea and it
eliminates the spoiler effect which
which deters a lot of people from voting
a
third party in the first place so that
that's one of the main attractions
david from st louis i really appreciate
the call i'm gonna let you go i know you
had a number of other questions but
we've got a bunch of people waiting so
we're gonna
uh keep we're going to keep going here
let's go to andrew from miami andrew
from miami you're on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can hey
so i was wondering what your thoughts
are on the jimmy door versus aoc
discussion that's been going on on
twitter are you familiar with it
no i'm not what what is what's going on
now i mean i don't
i think it's pretty important and pretty
interesting to talk about is jimmy dore
is currently trying to argue that aoc
and the squad
should force nancy pelosi to put a house
vote on medicare for all
by basically refusing to vote for her
for speaker of the house
okay and i think it would really do a
lot in
forcing the house to actually put that
to a boat and
bring it into the national spotlight as
opposed to just giving in to nancy
pelosi's
standard demands of making her speaker
like we do every time
does uh does nancy pelosi need
the four votes from the squad to become
speaker
so the the squad actually consists of
more than just four people
at this point i mean the progressive
caucus of the democratic party is
is around 100 people but hold on a
second
but the squad is not a hundred people i
mean maybe the squad is like six or
eight if you include some of the new
people coming in
so is is the claim that that
four to eight people should abstain from
voting for nancy pelosi or that the
entire progressive caucus
yeah so the entire progressive caucus
would be great but obviously not all of
them are actually progressive right
they're just there
for the name of it i guess i'm wondering
what leverage four to eight members of
congress have
to stop nancy pelosi from being
speaker i just don't have the math in
front of me yeah
the math turns out to be actually that
it would be a pretty close vote and even
some members of the progressive caucus
have admitted
that the vote could come down to as
close as you know
two to five votes if some people aren't
there for covet reasons etc so
there's actually some power in the hands
of the progressives in the house
and so what would be the goal of the so
they do a vote
and then and then what i guess the vote
so the vote would show that these are
the people who are against medicare for
all
during a national pandemic during this
covet crisis where 3 000 people are
dying per day
almost 300 000 have already died and
these people are against
voting for that guaranteed health care
during that pandemic and we've also seen
during this last
election that everybody who supported
medicare for all
won their runoff election mm-hmm so
there's a
yes that's true there is significant
self-selection bias
in saying that because you have to look
at well where did peop
in what were the races in which people
were running with that position so i
think there's a bit of a reverse
engineering problem there a chicken egg
problem
but more importantly don't don't we i
mean like i'm fine with votes for
whatever
you know uh do whatever votes people
want to do i think it's great
don't we know who's foreign against
medicare for all like aren't members of
congress
on the record isn't uh the current vice
president on the record having been for
medicare for all and then she turned
around and said that she's not so it
seems like
it's currently just for people to be for
it oh you're the president vice
president-elect you mean
yes sorry that's what i meant when
people are when it's advantageous for
people to be for it
they're for it yeah and then when
they're in positions of power they're
suddenly against fighting for it
so i think that's an interesting you
know conundrum there isn't it i mean
listen i think it's fine to do that
but it it seems also like either way
it's it's a political posturing thing to
like make a list of names of who's been
naughty and nice sort of
and and then the problem is it's not
going to do anything for anybody like it
will literally get us no closer to
getting everybody coverage
or a coronavirus stimulus or saving a
business that's about to go out of
business so
like i have no you know i the house can
do whatever it wants and sure do it
i don't know that they have the leverage
to even get nancy pelosi to do it and
even if they do
it's a beltway story in the sense that
people who
right now are about to lose their
business or not pay their mortgage
they don't benefit by getting a list of
members of congress that were
hypocritical on medicare for all would i
be curious
i guess but i just don't know that we
really are doing anything for the people
by making that the focus and remember
i haven't seen any of what you're
talking about on twitter i'm just taking
you at your word that you're describing
it accurately
interesting yeah jimmy dora was uh
trending over the weekend about it and
it was on rising and a few other
programs as well
okay yeah that's i guess that's probably
why i didn't see it i don't watch other
programs and i
didn't look at twitter over the weekend
gotcha
all right thank you very much appreciate
that
uh let's see where are we going next we
are taking
uh taking calls let's go to
sarthak from i believe it's boise idaho
is that correct yeah that is boise idaho
how you doing i'm kind of in like the
meridian eagle area but
pretty close to boise love it
so what's on your mind yeah so i just
wanted to say like
i i'm a big fan of your show uh it
really got me through this election
and all the ups and downs that it's had
i think and i guess my question is like
with with what trump's doing do you
think there will be like a republican
civil war or do you think
trump already kind of won it and that
it's now the party of trump because i
saw kyle kelinski talking about that
quite a bit
and i just wanted to see what your take
was i think we don't know yet and so
right now you're seeing
factions that are very angry with each
other earlier this week mitch mcconnell
acknowledged that joe biden is
president-elect and trump attacked him
on twitter
and then the q anon people started
tweeting they're leaving the republican
party
and you have trumpists attacking
republican georgia governor brian kemp
and republican georgia secretary of
state
brad raffensberger because they're
apparently unwilling to overtly try to
help trump steal the election they were
fine trying to do it by voter
suppression it didn't work
and now that's kind of where they're
drawing the line i just don't think we
know
yet i think the georgia results will
give us a signal given how close it's
been
if the democrats end up winning georgia
by a significant margin i think it will
be a sign that the republican civil war
had has
is is real and has an impact but really
what i think
the factor uh the the um uh what we need
to wait for
is how visible is trump after january
20th because i'll tell you
if trump disappears and just goes to
play golf and stops tweeting or even
gets banned by twitter once he's not
protected as a world leader
i think it will completely deflate the
sales of the q anon of the cultists and
of those folks
and we see the republican party reunite
pretend to care about the debt and just
oppose democrats
if trump remains visible or
he is replaced invisibility by some of
his kids or whatever if they keep it
going
that will continue the divisions between
the trump cult and the
sort of more mainstream republican party
i just don't think
we're going to know that until after
january 20th
okay and so like if they do like either
trump runs again or
like he announces it during biden's
inauguration yeah
there's like he buys newsmax and then he
starts his own trump tv
do you think that's their that's the way
that we have a civil war
yes or what just to go back to the
normal status quo kind of essentially
that's my view as of right now yeah
thank you so much my pleasure great to
hear from
boise idaho close to close to boise
idaho
uh we're taking calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's briefly go to
my friend pedro from colombia
yes oh mr pacman did you see the
mr biden who finally won
c yeah i thought he won
like a month ago but i guess he won
again he's won seven or eight times now
yeah i don't understand your american
system of
voting is kind of confusing you know
but i'm happy you know that he finally
won
again so muy and pedro
yeah so oh you know mr pacman you know
i don't really have much to say i was
thinking of starting and only fans you
know
but my wife you know i think if she
found out she might be a little
a little mad you know i wasn't gonna
post you know too many
you know racy pictures you know but
you know i just i got like some
i got a nice body you know i want to use
it for my advantage
oh miss bosa she's she's doing good you
know she
she didn't really care who won you know
uh well she kind of like joe biden more
she thinks trump's a little racist you
know
see i think he does understand spanish
at least it's very
interesting um yeah that's interesting
uh she doesn't like me to tell her name
you know
i just call her my wife you know and do
you have kids pedro
oh yeah pedrito he's my my pride and joy
and you know i love my little pedrito
you know
my wife she doesn't think i care about
pedrito and she always
kicks me out the house you know because
really she's like
but i do care about him you know oh
he's uh i think he's four years old i
forget you don't know
all right pedro uh thank you so much for
the call
okay good to talk to you mr pacman i
love your show
pleasure thank you so much yeah i don't
know that we'll ever really figure that
out i mean it's it's
i go back and forth as to what that is
and it's never never totally clear
okay let's take a very quick break if
you're holding on to talk to me
don't go anywhere because we will be
back right to the phones
momentarily the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense
them down into text or audio that you
can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right hearing from folks all over
the country and world
via our discord server which you can
find at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's talk
briefly to stavros from greece
we've never had a caller from greece
before stavros
stavros please unmute so that we can
hear you it would be a pleasure
how are you uh fine thank you
good um i was wondering like say
trump disappears from politics as you
have predicted may happen
yeah do you think any trump children
like i don't know don jr or ivanka maybe
will try to revive the trump brand of
say politics for a potential 2024 run
something like that i think it's
plausible but i think there will be
something intermediate
there are rumors that maybe lara trump
eric's wife
will run for senate in north carolina
that's a possibility and i think that
would be for 2022
there's the idea maybe of ivanka or
someone running for something short of
president so you you may actually see
that before you see one of the kids try
to run for president
and we you know we sort of have to see
how the next two years shake out
remember stavros they also could be tied
up in in legal investigations for the
next two or three years
and it might interfere with their
ability to run for anything i i just
have no idea what the next couple of
years look like for that family
um yeah and you don't see them maybe
like joining the mainstream republican
party and
mainstream ideas they sort of have i
mean that
see that's the thing the trump cultists
are sort of at odds with the mainstream
republican party
but for the most part while trump has
done his public scandals the republicans
have just kept doing what they'd be
doing anyway
passing tax cuts for the rich appointing
right-wing judges and justices
so the the trump uh kids and the trump
family
itself has mostly bowed down to the
republican party
except for cases in which they don't get
along like on stealing the election as
an example but i i
think that we just have to wait and see
yes of course um okay thank you very
much
my pleasure stop now what part of greece
are you in
uh athens athens i've never been but i
would love to go
uh soon i don't know whenever it's safe
you know
yeah it's really nice you should you
should come and is it uh
is it the type of city where you can
kind of get around easily on your own
as a first-time visitor i mean
you can it's not we don't have the best
you could say public transport system
okay but i i think it's doable
and what's the weather like right now in
december
i mean it's cold uh cold for you know
greek weather
um i think it's kind of like california
in general the climate here
so when you say cold how many degrees
are we talking about
i don't know probably 10 degrees celsius
oh my goodness that sounds
beautiful that sounds delightful
yeah it's nice yeah all right stavros
great
i hope to hear from you again my friend
okay thank you
all right stavros from greece very
strong um
let's go next because there is
uh there's just no shortage of people
here
trying to get on why don't we talk
to uh oh we have a philip
i can't see the name but we have a
filipino caller filipino caller what's
your name it's just not showing up
sir i am john christian from the
philippines
did you say john christian yes sir
how are you fine sir
well i have to say here that america
that
in america you voted for biden
right well in the philippines it's kind
of
a shambolic democracy because our
president
rodrigo duterte is at it again he shut
down abs-cbn
he read stunned political activists he
accuses
vice president leni robredo of showing
off in a typhoon and now
leonardo briones the department of
education secretary
our secretary said that
face-to-face classes will happen well
your secretary devos is similar
to so my secretary which is brione
so i have to ask you the question is if
president duterte
ends do you think he will go to the
international criminal
court because the icc said
that there is enough evidence to
say that he has cry committed crimes
against
humanity for murder for extortion for
political stealing
everything from his term in office
until life now
i think that it is almost without
question
that rodrigo duterte has committed
horrible crimes and and yet
i don't think it's particularly likely
he will be brought up on charges in
front of the international criminal
court i i don't see it as likely
unfortunately
unfortunately well i think the president
of the philippines and his
cult of supporters are as horrible at
trump supporters because i think you're
right they build lies
everything everything they call
um i let's say in filipinos
well it's talking about the liberal
party which
is the party before duterte
so my following question is
if joe biden and tamala harris did
they be unthinkable in 2020 what advice
will you say
to filipinos like me who will vote
in the 2022 philippine presidential
elections
because this is not about rodrigo
duterte this is the future of the
country
in the next two years and we have
seen here that duterte's allies can
cheat lie steal and manipulate just like
mr michaels did in the 1980s
right well listen i wish i had specific
advice but
without being as familiar as you are
with the specifics of how he will
attempt to remain in power
it's hard for me to say anything more
than generally
we need everybody to vote that that was
the meme here and enough people did that
we have we have removed trump
now you're you're shot out of a cannon
today you're completely on fire and i
have to ask
are you speaking into a phone but
talking through a megaphone
no i know i am not speaking to a
megaphone i am
here to tell the truth that
is a murderer yes a dictator a tyrant a
human rights denier
and there is no question that the icc
has proved
that duterte should be charged i think
you're right humanity
i think you're right i think you're
absolutely right and
we are going to uh listen very closely
and see if we can figure out how you
achieved such a unique vocal sound
uh it sounds almost like there's a band
saw going in the background but i'm
going to let you go
i really appreciate the call and wow
that is a high-energy call and i
sympathize politically
uh with the situation in the philippines
uh there's no doubt about that it's uh
it is something else let's go next to
ali reza in toronto canada ali reza
you're on the air
ali reza please unmute so that we can
hear you you are
on the air in toronto canada but i
cannot hear you until you unmute
yourself and configure your audio
and ali reza absolute last opportunity
it's sort of a going once going twice
going three times type of thing and ali
reza
is gone because ali reza was unable to
put everything together
let's next go to hamdi from norway hamdi
from norway you're on the air
yeah hello can you hear me yes i can
yeah do we have a specific point that we
have to hold to
a specific point yeah like for example
uh i have a question regarding what do
you think that the people on the right
side
uh on the political spectrum yeah get
away more
with lies compared to people on the left
side
ah beautiful so when you say they get
away with them
they get who isn't holding them in other
words when the right lies
the left doesn't punish them for it or
it's the right
that doesn't punish the right for lying
well both
because people on the left they punish
people from the left while the people
from the right
stick together like uh like it's
it's like a client with wolves you know
they stick together uh
thick and thin right i mean it's
different standards this is exactly the
point and
i talked about this a few weeks ago when
i explained
that the trump cult
is they don't think about facts and
truth
the way that we on the left do um
they believe that they are waging
essentially a war
and that they have the moral high ground
and so
when kaylee mcananny comes out and and
lies
and trump says he won georgia and people
at the rally in georgia say
fox now is liberal and you have to
listen to newsmax
they think that the it doesn't
matter whether they are telling the
truth in a literal sense because they
are in a war
where any tactic to win the war is
acceptable
the left doesn't have that perspective
and the left often will say
we're not going to stoop to their level
and this
is why the right gets away with lies
that the left wouldn't even let its own
get away with you
you're identifying this perfectly yeah
for example um we have a saying uh
as a as a
norwegian with from an immigrant family
of course um north african from western
sahara
okay so basically my dad came in
here in 1978 what i love about norway
for example
i never experienced races not even once
really
such yeah it's such we have a thing in
norway that's called
uh what in the end of london which means
like uh
our new our new people
it's interesting to hear you say that
because you know one of the arguments
that american right-wingers love to make
about sweden norway and finland is they
say
the reason that there's no racism there
is that
there's no people to be racist against
because everybody's white but you're
saying
even as someone who is uh in an
overwhelming minority there
you've never felt racism in that way
well well one thing is that
what's fun about this that uh i hate the
fact that americans
i'm sorry but americans think that their
country is the only nation with
immigrants for example i'm from a city
called
dramen and it's one of the biggest
cities in norway
and we have oslo which is like around 24
immigrants right like an immigrant
background so there's a lot of
immigrants in norway i think it's two
percent
two percent of the population is muslim
now and we have tons of vietnamese as
well
i think that's higher than the united
states i believe in the u.s only 1.5
is muslim or something like that it
might be one so it's between one and two
okay fair
fair uh the biggest immigrant group we
have here is a
swedish and pakistanis and now polish i
think if i'm not mistaken
okay but we have uh immigrants from
uh all parts of the world just like you
guys have so it's not really that big of
a difference yeah
um the thing about them i was going to
ask really is that
i find it really strange that the people
on the right
get away with racist terms without
when you call them out about it they try
to say they're not racist for example
we have uh people the right like you
guys have donald trump we have someone
called
silvelis a female i think uh
there was a colbert report maybe made
fun of her
because she um she and people in her
party
it was a term that called a sneak
islamic setting which is
a sneaky way of introducing
uh yes sneaky islamization it sounds
like yeah yeah
basically and i mean like if you said
that
stuff about jews like uh sneaky jews
trying to
uh invade our country if it did
something like that oh my god you
were called out straight away you know
well people do say that all the time
interestingly enough but yes you're
right
there's no head of a political party
norway who says that about jews
right somehow it's okay
to say this about muslims yeah and i
wonder why can people on the right side
get away with this with no consequences
yeah it's
uh well it's because there's their side
doesn't think there should be
consequences that's that's the that's
the exact
difference and you know people say well
the left allows the left to get away
with the same no they don't it's like
you know here we have this anthony
weiner scandal
as soon as anthony weiner was caught
with these texts
democrats just disavowed him and that
was it when there was a guy caught with
ten thousand dollars in his freezer for
some bribe it was like a decade ago
democrats weren't standing by him i
forget his name now so yeah it just
they don't they don't think there should
be consequences for some of these things
so then therefore there are no
consequences it's that simple
yeah well yeah hamdi listen i love the
call i've never been to norway but it is
high on my list
and i i would love to visit yeah it
would be great to
have you here now i've been to finland
what would be mo
if i liked finland what would be the
most notably
different thing about norway if i
visited yeah well
basically you say that for example we
have a company called
sector alarm which is one of the biggest
uh alarm companies in europe
so we uh opened a section for uh
finnish people well the thing is about
about finnish build they're known for
being
really quiet not like they don't like to
talk they don't like to
you know they're not really sociable but
as long as
as soon as you give them something to
drink they come really sociable
but the religions are more like they're
more tolerant they're very left-wing
and uh yeah that's why i'm saying never
experienced racism here
people are very open very friendly and
yeah i encourage everybody to come over
here and see for yourself
i plan to we used to have direct flights
from boston to oslo
now who knows you know but i will i will
make it there after the pandemic my
friend
yep all right thank you so much for the
call very much appreciate it
i'm sorry i was not able to take more
calls but we got some good ones i will
take calls again very soon
we will go to a break and be back with
more right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week we do have these
two
a special senate runoff elections coming
up on january 5th
the question i'm getting more and more
is can we trust the polls and the answer
is
it doesn't actually matter and i'll
explain why in a moment so as a reminder
we have two senate races that will
determine who controls the senate
they're both in georgia they're both
runoffs the first one is incumbent kelly
leffler
against challenger uh rafael warnock the
second is incumbent david perdue against
challenger
john ossoff there are no debates
happening in the office of purdue debate
because perdue said he won't he's not
going to do it that's after ossoff
absolutely obliterated him in the last
debate they had
we did see a debate between leffler and
warnock leffler appeared
to have a software malfunction where she
was just repeating the same thing over
and over again
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal laughter
on and on and on really weird but in any
case the polling
is very very close if you look right now
at the um ossoff purdue polling
it's awesome plus one on average if you
look at the warnock leffler polling
it's warnock plus a little bit over one
and of course
both races have polls saying it's
actually the republican who's winning so
the answer to can we trust the
georgia senate polls is it doesn't
matter and what i mean by that is
they're basically 50 50. if you trust
them
it's 50 50 and thus you have to vote
because it's going to be close
if you don't trust them then we don't
know what the race is
looking like in which case you would
just go and
have to vote so it's actually there's no
you know electoral college consideration
where well
if biden's winning nationally but in my
state he's not
and i vote but if in california it
wouldn't
no none of it matters it's it's
could not be simpler if you believe the
polls this is tied and everybody should
vote
if you believe the polls can't be
trusted then you should vote because the
real
polling could be anything and uh we
don't
uh in both scenarios we should be
getting out and voting now as a reminder
the importance
of these three elections should not be
understated these two elections rather
should not be understated with these two
seats
democrats would have a 50-50 tie in the
senate
and what this means is that the
possibility of joe biden getting big
campaign a policy done goes way up
because in the case of a 50-50 tie
kamala harris gets to
cast the deciding ballot as vice
president of the united states
you can't possibly overstate the
importance of this
i believe there is no chance of anything
being done on health care
if democrats don't take these two seats
i don't believe you will see big climate
and energy green energy legislation
if democrats don't take these two seats
i don't i don't even know for sure
whether you get tax reform
even done even negotiating with
republicans i don't know if you get tax
reform done
if you don't get these two seats now on
the counter side done the opposite side
to this
is the reality that many of you have
brought up when i open up the phone
lines
which is even with a 50 50 split
is joe manchin from west virginia the
most conservative
democratic senator going to vote for
some of the stuff joe biden wants
we don't know it's very very much
unclear
but it's also possible that you could
find
a vote or two from the republican party
among republicans
whose constituents are more moderate i
know it's almost like a meme at this
point but
susan collins in maine maybe lisa
murkowski in alaska
there are some possibilities uh but the
the important thing is that
without these two seats these aren't
even conversations so
phone bank text bank donate if you can
door knock safely if you're in georgia
we should all be focused in on these
races and we will
we will continue to be but whether you
trust the polls or not it doesn't matter
everyone must vote hey david so it turns
out hunter biden
is now being investigated so now what
will this be a cloud over joe biden for
his entire presidency
i believe the answer is no here's why i
don't believe so to back up the story
back in um the pre-election part of 2020
this outrageous conspiracy um was put
together
which alleged this is like a blend of
all the different things
uh hunter biden joe biden's son
needed to get some laptops with really
sketchy stuff on them repaired
so he flew across the country from the
west coast to the east
coast and brought these three laptops
while
drunk directly to a particular repair
shop
at which the person doing the repairs
and taking the laptops in was legally
blind and it's
unclear how well he was even able to see
who was dropping off the laptops
and then hunter biden after flying
across the country to get these
important laptops fixed
left them there and never picked them up
and what
the repair guy did was instead of i
guess
just trying to get the laptops back to
their owner he went in and read
hunter biden's private emails on the
laptop
and was convinced that it was hunter
biden
because one of the laptops has a bo
biden foundation
sticker on it this is the so-called
laptop from hell as it's been dubbed by
donald trump
then the repairman found what was on
there so sketchy
that he gave it initially i believe it
was to the fbi and when the fbi didn't
do
what the repairman wanted done with the
laptop after months the repair guy
called rudy giuliani
and gave him the hard drive or laptop
and the rest is history okay so
that's that's the story what is going on
right now with hunter biden has nothing
to do with that now what what hunter
biden
is in the middle of is an investigation
related
to reportedly i believe it's 110 or so
thousand dollars in
unpaid taxes hunter biden says he's
cooperating fully with the investigation
he believes he paid all the taxes he
should have and he's cooperating period
so this has nothing to do with a laptop
from hell first and foremost that's an
important thing to remember
and up i don't think that i mean listen
republicans have given the option
they'll do investigations they'll call
for a special counsel whatever
but uh hunter biden certainly um is not
going to be part of joe biden's
administration
i know that we may now because of donald
trump think well obviously hunter
biden's about to be
a high level advisor to joe biden no no
that that's
uh that that's not going to be the case
and
um as a result i i think that this is
not going
to generate um the sort of titillation
that many on the right are hoping now i
would find it fascinating if joe biden
came out and said
no one is above the law people should
get their day in court
and everybody should be subject to
investigation
if law enforcement believes there's been
wrongdoing even if it's the child of a
president of the united states
and step completely out of the hunter
biden thing which is going to be
resolved in due course and
of course the implication of joe biden
saying that would be
this also applies to don jr and to eric
trump
and to ivanka and to jared kushner and
whoever else
the conspiracy theories about hunter
biden will explode but i would be
shocked
if this became what some in the
conspiracy right
are sort of hoping that it will become i
may be wrong
and we will see david is there an actual
scientific
consensus on what covid policy should be
this is a really great question because
there are people who hear
the question can't we just empirically
determine the right coveted policy
and the problem with the question is
that it ignores
that every choice is subject to
trade-off so
i'll give you an example it has been
determined
beyond a doubt that given that the
contagion is mostly happening indoors if
you
limit indoor exposure without masks to
other people
you dramatically reduce your risk of
giving to giving or getting the virus
from someone
most contagion is happening within homes
and it's being brought in from elsewhere
and of course you reduce the risk of
bringing it in from elsewhere
if when you go to work if you're working
indoors or go to the grocery store or
you you wear a mask okay so it can be
easy to say
that's the science but when you talk
about
policy you're talking about a trade-off
there are people
i disagree with them but there are
people i walked by a guy on the street
the other day
who chastised me for wearing a mask in a
bakery as required by the bakery
um who say well okay that may be the
science of masks
but i don't believe the trade-off is
worth it the trade-off being i don't
like the way i look and it's
uncomfortable
that's a trade-off and the the science
can't tell you if that trade-off is
worth it because it relates to values
fundamentally
the the bigger one you know that that
would apply
is temporary shutdowns
during spikes uh slow the transmission
when they are adhered to and there's a
very interesting article i recently read
about
you know a lot of latin american
countries on paper have the strictest
shutdowns and yet
the virus is out of control what's
happening well people aren't abiding by
the shutdown and
there's no enforcement of the shutdown
as often as is the case
so even if you determine temporary
shutdowns
that are very finely tuned um are
clinically effective
and they also minimize societal harm
in terms of economic harm and
uh you know feeling like your personal
liberties have been taken away these are
like targeted okay
it's still a trade-off right you still
have to say well this is the
this scientific policy this policy has
been shown scientifically to reduce
transmission by this amount it lowers
the
r naught from something to something
lower than that
you still have a counter to that
and you still have to decide based on
your values whether it's worth the
trade-off so
i think that when we're asking the
question what is the scientific
consensus on coveted policy
what you're really saying is how much do
different policies reduce transmission
the societal question the government
question the cultural question the
economic question is
what is the economic cost what is the
psychological cost
depression or separation of people
loneliness etc
economic all this other stuff and that
is a different question than simply what
works scientifically
and to me i i continue to be shocked
that people are insisting on this
we we can't do all of this because we
have to save the economy we can't shut
down this we can't do that we get
all this all this different stuff how
are people still thinking that it's
um uh economy versus health
if we seriously had dealt with the virus
at the beginning
there might have been an initial
economic hit that would have been harder
but we're a year in we're on spike three
while most european countries are only
on the second spike we've got one of the
highest death rates in the world
if you look at the deaths relative to
our population it's completely
off the charts so the the idea that
we're we're also dealing with false
dichotomies about it's either health or
the economy
the economy has suffered greatly and
will continue to suffer and we're doing
disastrously poorly
when it when it comes to health so
we might imagine that all that matters
is understanding the scientific
consensus like
uh targeted and accu accurate really
well done
uh lockdowns work to prevent the spread
if people really do it
but there are downsides depression maybe
people you know
drinking a business permanently shutting
down
economic problems all that stuff but
there is no consensus about what is
worth it and that's where the conflict
is coming from now some people are are
you know making legal arguments
a government state government mass
mandate is unconstitutional no it's not
um but there are real questions about
what we we believe is worth it and we
came out on the wrong side of it lastly
uh that that's the important thing to
know which is if we had actually had
consensus
on you know a two-month we're 10 months
in we're almost a year and
if we had done a proper two-month
shutdown and really done everything that
that should have been done
we could have had a relatively normal
summer in many parts of the
of the country as many european
countries did that's uh
that's the unfortunate reality and
getting consensus
we can better get consensus on the
scientific even though you still have
people who say
masks don't actually work shutdowns
don't actually work well
if people don't wear the masks correctly
or if you announce a shutdown but don't
adhere to it yet that won't work
but if you do it right it does where we
have not been able to get consensus
is what is worth doing and what are
people willing to tolerate and part of
it goes back
to the complete bungling by the federal
government at the very start of this
entire thing
we've got a great bonus show for you
today make sure to
sign up and get instant access at
joinpacman.com
we'll see you on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're trying to quit smoking or
vaping check out lucy which is a
nicotine gum developed by
caltech scientists they'll ship it right
to your door and you can save 20
percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman blinkist is
the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or co-pays
visit
steadymd.com pacman to get started